welcome back to the 10 million dollar
studio i'm your internet detective
the guy you count on to deliver you the
facts of the case
uh here with my 10 million dollar studio
mug
hope you got something to drink guys
hope you got something handy because
we're getting into it today only the
biggest dramas
on trending tuesdays that's how we roll
now we're a drama channel
uh basically so right off to get into it
let's go to the big boy desk
come on let's go come with me there we
go look at that high level production
paid way too much money for this
what big big drama are we talking about
today
well uh i got a few topics for you guys
one big drama look at this guy
quitting youtube this might be the last
time i'm saying this
oh yeah you gotta have the sad piano
good job man
following the template
[Music]
until next time
goodbye it says thanks for the 15 years
goodbye
of course it's trending as usual three
million views whatever
he he's so sad he's so you know he he's
leaving forever he says this might be
the last time he says it
oh my god you're not smiling
[Music]
you're doing it wrong
you're crying you're not doing it right
then
you're doing it wrong
[Music]
stay safe be happy i'll see you in 2021
probably i thought this was a goodbye
video
i thought what is this all right i'm
gonna take the
thumbnail hold on
why does he have this in the video hey
guys i'm gonna manipulate my audience i
gotta take the thumbnail real quick me
crying hold on hold on gotta get that
light right
oh i can't believe it
goodbye guys alex wasabi slate's month
long
youtube hiatus guys youtubers going on
vacation
isn't news i mean i think we should be
allowed to go on vacation
but you don't need to cry imagine if you
at your job
every time before or before you left for
vacation you go into your office you go
boss this might be the last time i see
you uh
and if you're not smiling you're not
doing it
i can't even i can't even pretend
imagine how stupid that would be this is
what youtubers do
i don't know i'm saying anyone who fakes
a goodbye from the internet
deserves jail type just gonna say that
right now okay
anyways now next drama oh
hello bet you didn't expect to see me
here look i'm from the future
i'm not even in uniform right now
because uh guys unfortunately
a big drama happened last night that we
have to throw into the story cut in the
mix
so apologize if this doesn't flow
perfectly but we got to talk about
call me carson twitter lost its mind
last night
when allegations came out that uh this
popular youtuber with like five million
subscribers
uh groomed a 17 year old now
everybody of course lost their minds and
said oh this is terrible it's terrible
until it came out that he was 19 when it
happened so he was 19 years old talking
to a 17 year old
and of course as you know from the
internet uh they're very good at having
very
rational uh nuanced discussions about
matters of the law
yeah so anyway uh very nuanced balance
discussion was had
and of course the hot takes from the
internet had to come out uh before
before we had even heard anybody else's
side of the story call me carson
maybe a pedo allegations call me carson
allegations a neutral take
drama alert call me carson cobby carson
is not a pedo
commie carson is allegedly a pedo call
me carson is definitely a pedo commie
carson is a
pedo uh so i wanted to talk about this
real quick because it's a big drama
not that i really care because i think a
lot of this is overblown
and kind of dumb there's a bit of a
wrinkle because of course he
sent pictures back and forth with this
minor
uh so let's talk about that real quick
okay number one
a 19 year old talking to a 17 year old
is not big news guys
when you talk about these things the
difference in age matters guys back in
my day
all right i'm an old boomer now married
up
locked it up but i was dating my high
school sweetheart who eventually became
my wife
and uh yeah she's six months older than
me we weren't we didn't happen to be
born on the same day so there was a time
uh where we could have exposed your guys
we missed our opportunity
but where she was 18 and i was still a
minor and guys guess what we were still
talking
does that make her a groomer does that
make her
a pedo no dude no the only reason
anyone's being a big deal out of it is
because this guy's internet famous
so i'm gonna go ahead and say that is
off the table that doesn't matter
then you have this thing of like sending
you know pics okay now obviously i can't
relate because me and my wife we
didn't even uh hold hands until we got
married but
you know for the rest of you heathen's
out there i know some of you are tempted
okay yeah you go ahead and send
the snaps so what do we do about that
all right
look it's my opinion i know this is
going to sound crazy
but if you're going to go out and say
that it's not
a big deal if a 19 year old has sex with
a 17 year old
then is it a big deal that they
exchanged pictures um
i think that's kind of a weird thing
look i know all of you guys are lawyers
and i know all of your cops and you
perfectly understand
the you know the balance between age of
consent and romeo and juliet laws which
say that the age gap matters and i i
know you guys understand
where carson lives and all that kind of
stuff i don't care that's not what i'm
into
i'm into like do we really care do i
care
that a 19 year old was sharing pictures
with a 17 year old and vice versa no
no it happens literally every day and
probably most of you guys who are like
throwing stones and saying oh this guy's
evil
have probably done it too you were 18
and the girl was 17
or vice versa which happens also all the
time so the only thing left in this
drama
is that carson is an internet celeb guys
now i would know a little thing or two
about being an internet celeb so let me
tell you
this is where my boy messed up okay and
this is honestly why i don't talk to any
of you
i have a rule never talk to your fans
ever don't engage just if they come up
to you on the street say hey stephen i
wanna
i'm out and it's just you don't do it
because there is that weird
uh power dynamic thing that everyone's
been talking about lately
i do think that that is a real thing it
exists even though it sounds like a book
written by l ron hubbard
yeah power dynamics between fans and
their like
object of worship their celebrity i know
we're just in this celebrity obsessed
culture now so
you know that's that's real and so i
think that that was a mistake
but i also think he was 19 years old
like
i don't think that's giving getting its
proper attention here
the dude was 19. when i was 19
i was dumb as a box of rocks if i was
judged on that forever like people are
trying to say like lock them up
you know lock them up guys oh the cops
are coming carson
you're gonna be locked up no it's like
dude
this guy he's young uh he's figuring out
life like should he have done it no of
course not
but people are acting like he was some
puppet master people are going he
groomed her
he was like a puppet master grooming you
know like you're talking about some 31
year old talking to a 15 year old no
dude
this is some awkward and you can read
the chat logs because of course they've
been leaked
this guy is some awkward cringy guy who
doesn't know
how to handle you know relationships
with women and you can tell
i i don't think this is some master
puppeteer
of fans i think it was a mistake i don't
think he should have done it i think he
should in the future better understand
his relationship with his fans but is
this a
is is this a big drama i'm honestly
disappointed with drama
tuesdays or trending tuesdays right now
because feel like is this really what
everyone's freaking out about
i don't know i don't get it maybe i'm
missing something maybe you think that i
haven't understood
the complexities of the law here and
since you guys are lawyers i want you to
explain it to me in the comments below
explain to me where i'm wrong
because of course uh the minecraft
community
has been known for its nuance and
understanding takes so
uh yeah i whatever next
drama dream the minecraft youtuber oh
yes
we're getting deep inside of this i
found a secret never before released
video
i really want to talk about guys because
i really care about minecraft
speedrunning i may never have played the
game may never followed any of it but i
deeply care okay so let's check this out
together
here we go you don't know me fool what
what is this you disown me cool i don't
need your assistant social persistence
any problem i got i just put my fists in
my life is violence but violence is life
peace is a dream
okay i can't even play dude i can't even
get through two topics on trending
tuesdays before i want to go back to
what i want to talk about
[Music]
and what i want to talk about uh is this
guy
that's what i want to talk about guys we
haven't talked about it locked up
look i started the london real saga
because i was just fascinated
fascinated by what was going on but i
feel like i've left a lot of you hanging
and mostly it's just because i've just
i've wanted to just let the grift be the
grift
but lately he's done some things that i
just we have to talk about i'm sorry
guys no minecraft maybe minecraft next
trending tuesdays guys maybe we'll talk
about the big big drama in the minecraft
community
because i know you guys care about that
but today we gotta address this man
right here what have you left me what
have i got
last night in cold world my younger
brother got shot my homeboy got jacked
my mother's on crack
my sister can't work cause her arms show
tracks madness insanity live
improvanity then some punks claiming
they understand me give me a break
what world you live in death is my sec
now guess my religion
colors
[Music]
oh my gosh okay we got to give credit to
the guy who made that first of all thank
you for doing that that was beautiful
joe whitaker he did this oh my gosh so
funny my guy
that is amazing uh guys if you don't
know brian rhodes he's running for mayor
and you know i haven't been talking
about it because i don't want to call
attention to it look really no one's
covered this guy you look up
brian rose for mayor the only thing
talking about brian rose for mayor is
brian rouse
but he's been recently making some bold
claims
real bold guys he says he's winning the
election
hey i just wanted to check in with
everyone and let you know
that we are winning please tell me this
isn't real
and on may 7th we plan to move into city
hall and become
your next mayor for london at this point
there are only two people in this race
the current mayor of london the
incumbent and us
is that true is that real i'm sure many
of you
like me are getting uh triggered right
now
is it true that brian rose his digital
freedom platform is becoming the
official internet of london
i don't know and we are soon
to be actually moving into first place
check the odds
check the bookies out there every day
we become more and more likely to become
your next mayor of london
so okay you get the point guys we don't
have to play anymore that clip
he says check the odds check the bookies
word number two
guys and we're about to we're about to
move into number one we're in fact we're
about to move in
to first place and move in to win the
whole thing so my thought was
this needs some investigation and
there's only one man to do it it's me
the internet detective so i dug into it
i dug into his policies
i wanted you to know listen hey worst
case scenario what happens if the
megalomaniac
goes and he becomes the mayor of london
right
well after some long research i
discovered his policy platform
transform london 2021
sorry brian i'm in your way here his
vision
for london so i decided we'd go through
it together because i think it's very
interesting
what he's got going on guys i think you
should be very worried if i were you
the following is my transform london
2021 plan of attack now i'm gonna be
honest
the policies were so vague that i did
have to uh interpret them a little bit i
had
because it was just a bunch of
boilerplate stuff i didn't understand it
so i so i
did hire some experts to try to figure
out what brian actually means
okay so he says he's going to get london
back to work how's he going to do that
well he's going to reinvigorate
this economy of this great city by
forcing everyone to start a podcast and
asking them to take brian rose's
business course
50 of all profits will be donated to the
freedom platform
so if you're at the podcast he gave this
is good news for you you should vote for
brian
health first we will create the most
resilient citizens in the world who are
physically and mentally robust always
prepared for times of crisis we will do
this
by asking them to drink their own urine
on a daily basis
yeah that's right guys i mean i mean
brian rose understands health
on a you know psychological level
mental level spiritual level and you
know he's not going to let you go to pot
so you got to drink your piss like he
does
every day uh this is a real thing by the
way you think i'm joking
okay i'm here at london real world
headquarters waiting for mr timothy
sheaf
and i have a glass of a beverage
this is my own urine yeah that's a
it's a real thing that really happened i
think he's deleted the video so far but
hey it's the internet detective we
figured it out so yeah you got to do
that there'll also be break dancing
every third
saturday where you're required to head
spin for 30 seconds
huh i don't know that seems to play to
brian's strengths a little bit
in fact not only does he want you to
break dance anyone who runs for mayor
from now on has to be able to break
dance look he says it in a video
show me a mayor who can do that he wants
to challenge sadiq khan
to a break dancing battle where he
thinks his uh he played to his strengths
a little bit here you must be able to
head spin for at least 30 seconds
if you're gonna be mayor and more
importantly if you're gonna be a citizen
of london
otherwise you might get locked up next
on the agenda
we got science first and again this is
just if brian rose gets elected calm
down it's not going to happen but if he
doesn't
he will make london safe again by
implementing rigorous science-based
decisions when it comes to setting
policies
we believe there's been a
disproportionate response to the 5g
corona
oh wow okay right that has caused the
loss of countless lives and to let the
lizardmen take over
fair enough this can be remedied by
referring all questions of science to
our supreme
science czar dr david ike
congratulations sir david you got
yourself
um a bit of a raise there i think
nice okay uh education first what's this
about we will get london back to school
to ensure a bright future for our young
kids and we will remove the culture of
textbooks and instead every student gets
an hour of joe rogan listening every day
followed by an
hour and one minute of london real
listening
guys this is his policies i mean i'm
just reading off of his website
right i'm reading off of his website to
be clear we will create a marketplace of
ideas where censorship is no longer
permitted on our digital freedom
platforms
so long as i'm the one uploading the
content and or the person
talking has donated okay uh
yeah that i think is the maybe the worst
part is everything will be
siphoned through the london reel freedom
platform.tv
webpage so i hope you guys are used to
going to that page and putting in your
email
obviously you have to do that so the
question remains i mean look i know
you're sitting there looking at the
color of your own piss wondering
when it's gonna come to blows or
swallows
but don't worry guys because i also did
some digging not only into his policies
but also what's his likelihood of
getting elected is it true
that he's number two in the polls right
or in the betting the bookies the
bookies boys the bookies
well i got some bad news there honestly
bad news
yes it's true he is number two in the
pulse
what's going on is it true that he's
really got a what does that say a 20
chance of winning it's complicated
mystery because when you actually look
up the real polls
you know not just the sports bookie
website you find this this is the best
poll i could find
uh sadiq khan of course is way ahead and
then there's a bunch of people
and then i can't even get it on screen
right now
is other and
brian is one of the others they actually
just have this basket
of others where all the mayor candidates
because it's just so easy to run for
mayor
can go and that's where brian is so
what's going on
is brian in last place is he in second
place
it's a bit of a mystery so i looked into
how bookie's odds
are made and basically this is actually
what's going on
so in bookie uh oddsmaking you know you
obviously want to account for what is
the actual likelihood of something
happening but there's this other factor
which is that when somebody places a big
bet on something
the odds change because the bookie
doesn't want to be exposed to like a
huge risk
it's like let's say someone puts like a
million dollars on the underdog
well now that underdog even though
they're not likely to win
the bookie on that weird chance that if
they do win
they basically don't want to be bankrupt
so they change the odds to fit
themselves
better so let me give you guys a
hypothetical to explain uh this little
bookie making
let's just say a grifter looking for
attention wants to make waves
and he has a bunch of cash from free
donations
to his campaign let's say instead of
actually using that money
for good causes he places a bet on
himself
theoretically the odds would change and
he could tell his followers
he's in second place while actually not
needing to get any votes at all
he could completely bomb in the election
and just say it was the lizard people
so i know that's a little bit hey hey
let's go to the conspiracy board guys
because i know that's a little bit crazy
right a little bit pepe silvia
i know that's wild but i'm gonna just go
out on a limb here and say that that's
what's happening so so fear not guys
sleep well at night
knowing that brian rose isn't in second
place
in fact it seems like he's in last place
so the mystery is solved guys the
mystery of brian rose running for mayor
i hope
you feel like you've been kept up to
date with what's going on because i know
we haven't talked about him
and you might see his videos saying that
he's in first place whatever no
no somebody just placed a big bet on him
we don't know who
uh and his odds changed because of it
but literally
the polls are clear no one knows who
this guy is of course
look the challenge is is that when
you're running for mayor you have to get
actual people
in london to vote for you not like the
five
david ike followers who still haven't
realized that he used them
he used david ike like strictly for
clout those guys
like yeah they're a fan of brian rose
but those guys don't usually live in
london
you know the concentration is all over
the world he needs to convince people
specifically within the city and that's
not going to happen all right so that
concludes
trending tuesday um
let me know what you guys want to see
next i know you guys are very invested
sorry to clickbait you with the
the dream drama guys i honestly just
can't be bothered to talk about it today
but let me know what you're interested
in seeing and i'll make sure to deliver
for you guys
up tomorrow we got webinar wednesdays be
sure to check it out where we get
scammed so you don't have to
thanks for watching and i'll see you in
the next
[Music]
you